what three creators do you see that you
think could become billionaires is like
Mr Beast dude perfect or something like
that and then they said to you no way
the algorithm has shined upon Him Cody
is one of the biggest YouTubers on the
platform doing what you do if you go and
listen to my first episode of my podcast
it was complete garbage if I'm thinking
about like what makes a good podcast or
what makes a good YouTube video or what
makes a good song the number one thing
you can do is
how much are you thinking about like the
business side of of without being a
billionaire
when I was younger it was like literally
just about the Creator but now that I'm
getting older it's like I want the
business to succeed
and then he looks at his phone he's like
elon's been texting me and then he
showed us his phone it was like Elon
Musk who's like come over you know he
was like should we go over to his house
yeah I mean you can't really say no to
that and so he got in cars and drove to
his house we got to his house and him
and Grimes are like standing on the
driveway with lanterns like welcome to
what that's insane what's he like like
it was one of those things where we
[Music]
by the way I listen I list this is like
one of my favorite podcasts oh hell yeah
so it's an honor to be on it right
because I it's one of two that I listen
to
yeah obviously but yeah
um they're good too I like them too yeah
so you guys just switched between you
guys and how I built this
and you lit so you listen to the part so
you kind of know the the vibe and so I
invited you to come on uh did you think
about like what are we gonna like
because it's different than our normal
episodes right yeah yeah Sam's not here
second yeah you're like cool
entertainment guy and we're usually like
nerdy Tech guys
um what'd you think was gonna happen I
don't know but I like being the guest on
a podcast is so much better than being
the host of one right because like it's
like that's your right side yeah the
pressure's on you I can just sit here
and answer questions you know yeah good
okay well that's what we're gonna do but
the actually the interesting thing is
you actually started as a kind of nerdy
Tech guy too I did yeah you were uh I
think like an iOS Dev yep and let's
start there so the origin story is you
uh you go to Duke and you you make a
viral app at one point I don't know if
we were at school or right after school
it was anyway I was during college
during college I was uh what did it
actually do so I know it was called CAP
that or I cap that I'd cap that I'd cap
that yeah what was the app a very funny
name by the way yeah
um so it was like I was a senior in
college and uh I was on the diving Team
all four years so I like didn't have
like in the Summers and stuff I was just
training
and so I never did an internship I
didn't have any resume by the time I was
a senior and all these all my like peers
were doing internships and they had jobs
lined up for as soon as I graduated I
didn't I had nothing and that kind of
scared me because I'm Canadian and I
wanted to stay in the states so I needed
a Visa which means I needed a job and I
also just like needed money and stuff
for when I graduated I was like [__] am
I gonna do
so I was studying computer science at
that time
and uh they didn't have an iOS class but
I was like I was obsessed with my phone
obviously and
I was like I really want to know how to
make an app so I just bought a book
taught myself and then like you know the
way you really teach yourself something
is you sure you can like read and watch
YouTube videos but like it's by you know
thinking of a project and then trying to
make it come to life so that was my
project there was one that did something
similar but it was a paid app and I was
like oh this is a perfect opportunity
because it's not a hard idea and what
was it so you're captioning yeah like as
a meme meme generator basically yeah it
was like you would select a picture from
your library or take a picture and then
it would it had like an internal
database of funny captions that we all
just like got drunk and came up with and
so it would automatically apply one to
the picture in white font but like
all the captions were sort of General
enough where people thought there was
like AI going on like what's an example
like what do you mean like like I don't
know a super one like a stupid one would
be like you take a picture of someone in
here and it'd be like addicted to
cocaine or something like that and
people would appreciate that you're like
oh he is that's so true
he does look like a cokehead and so it
and okay so then the way I got it to
spread is it got rejected by the Apple
review you know board or whatever
multiple times and so I was like for
being inappropriate so I was like hey
how did I can't make this app clean
because then it's not funny right and it
won't do anything so I basically had the
I wrote some code so that the internal
database was timed because I knew the
app review process took like a week
right so then basically after seven days
it would release all the dirty captions
so I got by the Apple review system
amazing and then everyone was like oh my
God this app is so wild like look at
this like swear words in it and it just
blew up it was the number one app in the
app store you're just on camera above
like eBay and Google and it was number
one and I paid zero dollars for
marketing right and I'm on campus like
I don't know what to do
because I know I should be making money
from this but I'm not and I have no idea
how to make money or anything about
business right and I was talking to my
friend I was like what do I do and he
was like dude you should like sell ads
and I was like I don't know
how do I even start to do that right
like I didn't know the first thing about
setting up like a ad SDK or anything
and so and you also kind of know your
shelf life like you know every day that
you're the top is great exactly and it
might not be the case 100 days from now
when I figure this out and when you blow
up that fast the graph goes the other
way just as quick right so I was
stressing on what to do and
I got an email from a CEO of a startup
in Palo Alto and he was like Hey saw
your app I love it I want to hire you
and buy the app
and I was like perfect yeah that worked
out which was cool for me because like
growing up you know being obsessed with
apple and Steve Jobs I was like Silicon
Valley is like a dream that's where I'd
want to end up is this it this is the
yes this is it yeah amazing no this is
I'd kept that too the sequel so like
when this company I surprised you didn't
go like dos or something I know right
did I tell you this on on my podcast I
don't know okay when so I I took a trip
to Palo Alto fell in love with it met
the team they loved they like you know
we just got along great it was a it was
a mobile ad SDK company yeah it was a
mobile ad Network so they needed my app
to drive traffic through the network
cool and I needed money and a job right
so they like it was you know pretty um
mutually beneficial they acquired the
app I think it was like for 50k half in
cash half in stock
which was great for me it was a nice
like lump sump yeah get a lump sum sorry
to get like a apartment and furniture
and stuff and then my first job was to
make was to make a sequel that was a
paid version
oh no actually no the my first job was
to make it I cap that plus which was the
paid version right and we we launched it
and immediately it made 200 Grand and I
was like damn it wow
damn it you should have just done this
by myself you're early to the plus train
but there wasn't apple and then we did
ESPN plus
yeah I haven't patented actually and so
then we made I kept that two and then we
made I kept that two plus and we just
milked this thing how much this do you
think the whole generator made like half
a million bucks or something like that
but then you know then it died yeah but
and so you had you had that run of like
you're doing that on campus so you got
the taste of like the thrill of making
something succeeding kind of failing but
also succeeding at the same time where
was your head at at that point you're
like what are you thinking at that
moment you're like oh I could just do
this again or what was your approach
after that like after I got the job just
like after you had gone through that
experience like did you think of like
I'm gonna do this again or what was your
it definitely was my first like little
taste of
independent success
so that definitely gave me a little
courage
um like my plan was okay I'm just gonna
State this company and work my ass off
and try to try you know do what I can to
make this thing a success so that like
the stock you know becomes something and
that didn't happen
um but yeah it was like definitely
it gave me my first little taste of
success and before that I had never you
know had I had never like felt momentum
like that before where something's
working and the graph is going up and to
the right and you're like oh my God I'm
onto something right and then you tasted
that again when you started doing like
content right Vine Vine content was the
next time you tasted that like that kind
of crazy virality I actually that was
more everything since then has been more
linear really yeah like I've never been
you know you see creators all the time
that blow up like out of nowhere
like you know this year it was like Alex
Earl or something like that sure or um
who else like the octopus octopussy kid
do you know him no anyways it happens it
seems like it sounds promising though he
sounds like he's really cool like a gym
um he's really funny but for me it was
always like I kind of had to grind my
way to having an audience right by
literally downloading Vine making videos
every single day
I was I was actually pretty late I would
say like the whole first like class of
you know like famous Viners had already
been a thing like King badge right
Brittany furlin they were already like
people right that everyone recognized so
when I downloaded it I was just like I
didn't download it with the intention of
like being somebody or
you know generating an audience or
anything like that I just was I was
working on a social media app for this
company and it was like Snapchat for
video basically
and then Snapchat for video came out
yeah you're like damn it and so
basically I was like just keeping tabs
on all the new ones that were coming out
and Vine came out so I downloaded it
started playing around with it and I
lived alone in Palo Alto which has a 21
year old it's the most like boring life
imaginable so I would just start making
videos I would get home from work and I
just all of a sudden like started
feeling like I was like flexing my
creative muscle and hadn't done that in
a long time yeah I felt good
so every day I would just make more
videos and then it was like getting
involved in the community you know like
making online friends with the other
people that were kind of getting some
traction and then I started showing up
on the popular page and people started
recognizing my face and I just kept
doing it like
just was genuinely like didn't try to
make it a job I just was like
programming is my job this is my hobby
and I'm gonna treat it like an art right
sort of
and that that sort of paid off because
like people I think people liked the
sincerity behind it and you what do you
mean by that so like for the people that
were let's compare the people that were
trying really hard to like become famous
on Vine and what you were doing what do
you think was different to The Outsider
I think like selling out was a much more
obvious thing
back then or a much more like binary
thing whereas now it's like completely
expected it's like someone someone takes
off and they start doing ad reads and
their fans are like yeah get the bag
let's go whereas back then it was like
first of all six seconds is really hard
to endure something in like you can't
even say get the bag exactly so it was
pretty obvious when people like started
making money and then people would be
like ah
you know you sold out you're not the
same right so I think that it helped
that I had an actual job on the side
that I was making decent money
but you got to a couple million
followers right yeah yeah I think I'd
like
yeah I think I had like three or four or
something and on Vine I always wondered
something like that or maybe two I don't
know what happened to Vine
I think it was just a little bit ahead
of its time
because I think now
I mean if it came out like five years
ago I feel like it would have worked
but it was kind of working then and then
they just like turned it off I think it
was because when Twitter Twitter bought
it before yeah they launched then they
launched it and it really worked but
then like the traffic started tapering
off and I think they were at a
Crossroads where they were like we can't
monetize just just our website right
like Twitter was having a really hard
time monetizing I think it still is
and wasn't there like a meeting with
creators where the creators like we want
money and Twitter was like nah and then
they wasn't there like some famous I
remember there was something like that
where they yeah I think they like were
in a room with like king bash and those
people and they were like we want this
much money to keep posting and they were
like we don't have it right
they're like okay yeah yeah yeah so
they're like actually we're just gonna
shut up shut down the whole thing
instead
yeah oh okay
um so you okay so you go through that
you uh you guys have had you've been
doing content on like podcast YouTube
for like over 10 years probably almost
right yeah almost
and you said you know it was kind of
linear so if I said like what was kind
of breakout for you well or like the
breakout moments or like things you
remember were like oh [__] things just
got different for me like I something is
different I don't know exactly how how
big this is but like something changed I
remember I remember the first time that
I hit a million views overnight
it was like a it was a that's cringe
video which was like one of now like
wonderful viewed series
on my channel and uh I remember like we
did a couple and they seem to be working
people seem to be into them but it
wasn't like apparent how much more
people liked them
than you know the other stuff that I was
doing and then we post like the third or
fourth one
and I remember waking up to a million
views and I was like oh my God that is
that was unfathomable for me you know
even five months ago right like those
numbers just like don't even make sense
to me and uh so that was one pretty
distinctive moment another one was when
we
when then me and Noel went on tour for
the first time and the second time and
all the times after that and the tickets
would just like sell out
and I was like see that was a moment
where I was like I can't believe that
this is now converting into Real World
Sales where people want to come to a
venue and see us in person that felt
really cool that's always like a weirdly
sobering thing what do you guys do when
you do that because we did uh we've done
I think we did two live shows this year
um both times they like you know people
showed up which was like shocking in the
moment and afterwards uh but also we
were like what the what do they want
like what are we supposed to do podcast
like you want to just do the podcast in
front of you while you're sitting here
like yeah I know that's boring I think
yeah um and we tried to do a bunch of
stuff
uh I personally hate it I hate I'm like
I don't really want to do that again
because
like you know your series is called
that's cringe that's in my head I was
like this is cringe right now what's
happening is a little bit cringe what do
you guys actually do when you do your
live stuff we did uh so like the first
couple shows that we did were just uh on
stage like podcasts because the same
thing we didn't really know and then
what do people want to see I'm not sure
they're buying tickets for a live pocket
500 people just sitting quietly
listening our first show is like a
hundred or something like that or
whatever there's a crowd of people just
watching the podcast yeah and that went
well but you guys are funny I think
that's the thing they're laughing so
it's kind of a comedy show yeah yeah so
I think that works but then we so then
after that we did another tour where we
were like okay we can't we need
something that's gonna like guarantee
laughs and we really want to want to put
effort into this so then we wrote a show
and then we started writing songs for
the show and it kind of became like a
third music a third like live sort of
that's cringe that we did on stage
gotcha and then a third like just
stand-up comedy wow um because Noel was
a stand-up before we started doing
anything together so he kind of already
had jobs and in research for this I saw
a video of you doing stand-up what yeah
where there's a video oh my God please
please do not look that up please for
the love of God I do not want to see
that
on my own channel dude I'm taking that
it wasn't that hard for me to do this
research by the way
what's it like doing stand-up horrifying
horrifying the thing is I I DJ Now yeah
I've heard and so I like that's in front
of people and I find myself like a lot
more comfortable obviously because it's
not just you and the mic and the
audience DJ there's something in between
which is already awesome you know it's
like music right so you for the live
shows you guys are like turning it into
like a full yeah by the end of the tour
because we did a we we toured the whole
world right and we did like I don't know
like 100 shows or something like that so
by the end it's like we had the show
literally word for word
scripted and memorized right because
when you do it that many times it just
becomes the same show and then you like
alter it a little bit every time if
something ought to laugh you'll add that
back for the next one and it kind of
evolves so we had Samir from Colin and
Samir in here yesterday and I had asked
him a question like
um
I think we said something like you know
uh what three creators do you see that
you think
um
like could become billionaires like you
talked about Mr Beast great who else who
else you think has that pathway or
potential and he said he's like Mr Beast
uh he said apparently he said dude
perfect or something like that
and then he said you no way yeah really
yeah and I was like that's amazing
because he named 50 other YouTubers by
the way during the episode that I was
like oh cool I never heard of these
people because I'm not like in the like
I have the things I like and I'm not
like YouTube culture I'm not like
everywhere on YouTube yeah and I was
like dude he's coming in here tomorrow
I'm gonna tell him this and see how he
reacts and you sound surprised uh I
definitely am surprised the thing he
said wasn't like he's going to be he's
like
uh they could he's like it's up to them
yeah he's like they totally can if they
if they choose to like optimize in that
direction
they are like the ones who have like the
the kind of the audience the
intelligence and like the kind of the
capability to do stuff there or they
might take that energy in a different
direction yeah
um I also uh I was telling Ben all the
way over here I was like I was like I
feel like you and Noel could do a uh
like Harold and Camargo to White Castle
movie yes yeah yeah um so we are working
on something I can't really say too much
about it but I'm a believer that that's
like sewing your guys's wheelhouse I
think it'd be a lot of fun I remember
aside uh when I was younger I acted in a
movie like as a kid like a kid actor of
a thing and my older brother in the
movie was Cal Penn who is oh yeah so he
called me one day and he was like uh hey
how's like school going right like I
don't even know what I had to say I was
like how's your what do you do what are
you doing now and he's like oh I'm
filming Harold and Camargo to White
Castle which to me I didn't even
understand what I didn't know what White
Castle was there was none where I was at
so I thought it was a fantasy movie okay
I was like yeah yeah I guess he's like
going to some fantasy Epic Castle thing
and I remember going to school and tell
my friends like yeah why did he call you
just checking in on me here's a nice guy
he was just saying you were like friends
with him after that because like because
you were saying like you know when you
go on tour you hang out like yeah same
thing on a set you just sit there right
right nine hours waiting for them to
line up the shot yeah do like five
minutes of acting then you just sit
there again like so he was just checking
up on you like what's good yeah he was
like what's good man like you know how's
your summer going
um I don't know anymore
he came to speak at Duke actually and I
was like I went up on stage and I was
like oh I look totally different than
like when I was 11. and I was like Yay
no
that's really funny he seems like a nice
guy oh he's Ultra nice uh really nice
guy he's also I really like about him is
he um
he just like grinded super super hard at
a time there's like no Indian actors
like the only Indian acting jobs he
could get was like you're the
convenience store guy you're like thick
accent and I remember talking to him on
set I was like what are you gonna do
after this and he's like uh he's like
talking to his agent or something and
he's just kept turning down roles
because he's like they just want me to
be the stereotypical Indian guy yeah and
I was like um okay cool Sonic what do
you do is set he's like I don't have
anything and there's no instead I was
like so and he's like he's like I have
no money and I'm just gonna like I'm
gonna just wait till I get a real he's
like if I do that I'll never get out of
that yeah yeah so I'm just gonna like
risk it all and like grind through this
period of like not having anything
um until I get there that's funny I I
took a I've told the story before on my
own podcast but I took an acting class
one time and they were talking about
leaning into your Typecast at the
beginning of your career like you have
to do what you look like
in order to like get your foot in the
door right so we did this exercise where
we all went around this the circle like
this was like a you know room full of
students it's like 20 of them and we all
had a journal and we would all like one
by one look at each other and write down
what we thought they looked like and
their Typecast was
and so like and then we all revealed
them basically like one by one they the
the teacher would point to one of us and
then the rest of the students would read
what they wrote about that person
so it was like it was like doctor
scientists you know and it was like uh
you know race car driver cool [__] and
then it gets to me and they're like
influencer cokehead DJ sells Coke in the
bathroom it was literally like five
minutes of just the most offensive [__]
oh I looked like a douchebag and I was
like damn but I mean I guess that's
spirit influencer and a DJ now so
I don't know too much about your
lifestyle but like yeah this is what
ended up happening
yeah he nailed it he actually had a
similar thing he's like got a call he's
like oh yeah I'm gonna be on CSI and
they're like CSI it's a terrorist plot
he's like oh man come on dude damn it
and he actually what he did was he
changed his name so his name is not
actually Cal pen his name is like kelp
and Modi and he's like I'm not getting
any auditions for the roles I want so we
just created a fake name by splitting
his first name yeah and then he started
getting calls in and then they're like
he shows up he's not white and they were
like oh
okay Acer here go ahead and read the
role and see what happens yeah yeah
actually the funny thing is the one of
the bigger roles he got was like Indian
doctor on house and I was like ah you
split the difference
but like you know still kind of
stereotypical in a way
did you when you were like trying to get
better at what you were doing
um how did you do that because like
obviously you get better by just doing
reps but sometimes you know if I want to
get better or something I might you know
hire a coach read a book take a class uh
like study and break down people are
already good at it like how did you get
good at doing what you do was there a
any intentional kind of process you went
through I think a lot of the times
um if I'm
thinking about like getting what makes a
good podcast or what makes a good
YouTube video or what makes a good song
I'll just like consume a lot of it and
just think about it a lot
but I mean like the number one thing you
can do is just do it
you just learn by doing at least for me
um so that's that's how I've Gotten Good
is just reps over time because like if
you go and listen to my first episode of
my podcast it was complete garbage right
it's just something I've gotten better
at I'm still not that great at it but
like I've gotten better at it through
the years right
um and now I'm going through that sort
of with like music production too it's
just like I'm at the beginning stage
where I'm like everything I make is a
little bit better
and just leaning into that the joy and
like Conquering the zero to one phase
and
yeah just like learning to enjoy that
part of the learning curve I think is
really important what are some things
you figured out that made like let's say
that that cringe series which now has
like I don't know 150 million views on
that that that style of video that you
do what's something you figured out
you're like oh that's I used to do it
this way then I figured out this and
made it better
I don't know if it's really anything
conscious
you know it could it's like it's mostly
stuff that you just like innately pick
up on when you do things over and over
again when you read comments and think
about what people are reacting to
um
but you know a lot of the times it's
like the first time we did a video like
that you know we were trying to riff and
kind of stepping over each other's lines
and jokes and punch lines and stuff and
the next time we did it we got a little
bit better at like letting each other
speak and breathe and like that's one
thing that I think we're really good at
now is we never speak over each other
like we never interrupt we're really
good at riffing but like because we're
innately just conscious of like
you know the audience and what they want
to hear and no one likes to hear people
interrupting and
stepping all over each other's jokes you
know
um so stuff like that
um
we just get better at like just because
you do it you know
uh I like that answer even though I
wanted you to say like the trick uh it's
like a lesson I've had to relearn so
many times that they're really like you
know there are things that make things
better but they're like there wasn't the
trick yeah it was like a shitload of
reps yeah and caring and then like you
know you're just sort of like get better
with every rep but there's like there's
kind of the boring it's like the it's
not the answer that's like yes
I found the secret
I don't think it would be fun if you
went from zero to good at something just
by doing one little trick because it
doesn't you don't like I find so much
joy in
in like getting a little bit better at
something every time I do it and then
seeing a little evidence of that what
you get by posting online right like the
next time you do something you obviously
need you know five comments being like
wow this is better than the last one you
did and you're like [__] yeah yeah I'm
getting it you know that drives me I
love that feeling we had uh Mark Manson
come in court here uh the day before and
he he has this thing he said is like
uh happiness uh people think happiness
comes from not having problems happiness
comes from solving problems yeah totally
and I was like oh yeah but it's like so
[__] true and um the better version
of that it turns out is like when you
um when you feel like you chose your
that problem
so like if the weather's just bad you
know yeah you know it's like oh I didn't
choose this it's happening to me yeah
but if you're like you know I wanna like
for you you're like doing these long
right 50 mile races 100 mile races or
whatever it's like you're choosing a set
of problems that you're gonna get you
know struggle but get satisfaction with
as you overcome them yeah
um right now what are those for you so
it's like the endurance stuff
maybe the business stuff is like that
too for you or no uh yes for sure both
of both of those things let's let's talk
about the business stuff so on the
business side uh you know a lot of these
creators are building Brands off their
style like products yeah I mean for me
it was like investing or other stuff are
you doing any of that stuff I am yeah
I'm developing something that I'm gonna
launch in the fall but uh for me it was
always kind of difficult I would see
people doing it and I was like this okay
this seems obvious and then I would
think like the money that people are
paying us to promote their [__] on the
show
like
expressvpn for example they've been a
sponsor of the show for years and
they've probably paid us like you know
if we totaled it all up it's like an
insane amount of money right but their
return on investment must have been way
higher right otherwise they would then
be crazy to re-buy the ads year after
year
so I'm like why don't we just like it
just makes sense for us to own Something
That We're promoting because then we see
all the upside right
um but it it was always
it always kind of killed me thinking of
the right thing
because I don't want to force anything
on on my audience
uh and comedy is a very hard thing to
like align with a product or a service
because it's just something that people
enjoy it's not
you know it's not like I don't know
it's not like Fitness or cooking where
there's like products that people use
every time they cook
with comedy it's not like that it's uh
it's just like I don't know generic and
sort of so I like when I started doing
the endurance stuff that's when I was
like oh there's a lot of stuff that I'm
doing every day yeah that it's natural
for me to promote and this is really
cool Cody's run Club yeah so this is
kind of
kind of my first
like uh product in this direction
where like I wanted to make something
more like Fitness focused
um so this is like the first time I've
done like running shorts for example
when you're promoting it are you doing
because that little like video that was
on there was kind of funny are you like
using the like are you leaning into the
humor side are you trying to be like
more serious when you're promoting the
stuff
uh that's something I still kind of
battle with myself over how serious
because like I always want to be
but comedy is a very easy crutch to lean
on because it's like I like making fun
of myself and also if I'm a little bit
self-conscious about something it's like
oh I was just joking
so like this you know it's like a hard
for me to sit in a studio and actually
make a fitness video because I'm like
I'm not that guy right I'm just doing
endurance races because I like doing it
it's a challenge but I'm not the guy
that's out there like in slow-mo like
you can do anything right now
so I like I like to blend the two I mean
that was great like you're just like on
the bike and the guy's like spraying it
yeah spring the Mist in your face to
like look like you're sweating that's
great so yeah this is like my first you
know time kind of
generating a product and like the more
Fitness lane and then I'm gonna do
something else that I think will
hopefully be a little bit bigger it'd be
funny if you were just sort of the
anti-david Goggins like just went the
other way yeah stay soft yes
marshmallows just sign off with
something so so incredibly soft do you
uh you listen to a lot of his stuff uh I
do I mean I read his bro his first book
and uh I've listened to his like Joe
Rogan episodes and stuff like that you
should uh have you read the book uh
living with a seal no
um it's a great book there's an
entrepreneur named Jesse itzler do you
know him have you ever heard of this guy
Jesse it's it'sler no he um so he
married the woman who created Spanx okay
um he and then he created like
Spanx like the concept the action
the uh spanking uh yeah that would be
big that would be that's a big idea
she uh sorry and he created like he
started off as a white rapper and then
uh he's always like white rapper things
like all right not gonna make it as a
rapper so he's like I'm gonna work in a
um record like a record label so he's
like working as a record label his
intern was uh like this guy who's trying
to be this rappers trying to be all hard
he's like yeah I like this guy it was 50
Cent so 50 Cent was his intern for a
little bit 50 Cent goes off blows up so
he's like okay
um he's like that guy like had it I
don't really have it but he's like what
do I what can I do he's like he started
creating Jingles so like rap Jingles
okay so he's like um he created the
Knicks theme song like the New York
Knicks like go Knicks go whatever go New
York go and so he created sports like
jingle like kind of like quick wraps for
companies okay and then he sells that
company for like at a 4 million all
right I got four million bucks I split
it between the two guys what do we gonna
do now that we got two million bucks and
they after they sold they met a rich guy
who took him on a private jet
and they were like flying in this
private gender like this is amazing we
would love to do this more we can't
afford a jet so like it'd be cool if you
could just own like a couple rides on a
jet like a piece of a jet like what if I
could just flange that 10 times that'd
be amazing yeah timeshare for jets so
they created that ended up selling that
jet or something they sold it to netjets
so uh there was like Marquee I think it
was there so and so they sold it to
netjets which was owned by Warren
Buffett that was a huge sale and then
now he like owns a piece of an NBA team
he like you know zico coconut water he
like invested a bunch in that early on
when he was like oh coconut water is
going to be a big thing yeah uh because
he's an endurance athlete so oh nice I
love doing long runs and so he he's like
the running Community loves coconut
water I think mainstream is gonna too
yeah so he found a small brand that
wasn't doing that well put a bunch of
money in and they ended up like selling
it to Coke later I listened to that how
I built this episode it's that's like
one of my favorites the coconut water
one yeah if you're looking for a good
one yeah look look up Bad episode and
watch that it's great
lion info have you heard of HubSpot
ERM platform so it shares its data
across every application every team can
stay aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
or dueling databases HubSpot grow better
foreign
I gotta tell you about one thing that's
one of the great joys of my life and I'm
not a cars guy I'm not a watch guy but
there's one thing that gives me a lot of
joy and that is having a virtual
assistant uh you know here's the
scenario I'm running my companies and
even though I'm supposed to be this uh
CEO we all know I spend 20 30 of my time
just doing random [__] stuff that is
not high value but it's just tedious the
stuff that has to get done
but it's not creativity it doesn't
require me and it doesn't add a bunch of
value to the business it's just stuff
just stuff that has to get done and so
that stuff is what a virtual assistant
does like just this week alone you know
I lose my wallet so she goes to the DMV
website fills out a bunch of forms it
gets me a new license or um you know
every morning people have their morning
coffee I have my morning metrics and my
morning metrics are basically all the
business metrics that I care about
compiled she goes she finds it for all
the different sources puts it in Excel
sheet takes a screenshot text it to me
so that when I wake up in the morning I
don't go on Twitter or check my email
I'm looking at what are what are the
metrics at and what do I need to do I'm
focused on the right things so having a
virtual assistant is a no-brainer
whether it's travel booking email inbox
or just knocking stuff off your personal
to-do list that would have just lingered
there forever
um I think it's a no-brainer if you're a
business owner you should definitely do
it
um I think one of the best ways to find
a assistant is Shepard so go to support
shepherd.com you know I pay my assistant
I think eight dollars an hour something
like that that's double what she was
making in her previous job so it's a win
for her and for me it's super affordable
it's something that you know you don't
need to have the biggest business ever
be the biggest big shot in order to
afford it so it's amazing I now do this
for my CEO and my cm02 like I just give
them assistance without them even asking
because I know it makes them more
productive that's it does that for me so
of course it's going to do that for them
too so go to sportsshopper.com check
them out
um get an assistant and tell them I sent
you they'll take good care of you if you
do that so sportsrefer.com check it out
and one of the things he did along the
way was he was like I don't really want
to run this like I guess there's some
hardcore race in Arizona or whatever the
hardest race Death Valley or something
something like that and he goes there
and he sees uh people running and then
he sees
um this guy he's just like a huge guy
running this race and he's like by
himself
um he's like bleeding and he's running
and it's David Goggins essentially and
he meets him and he's like hey I want to
run this race next year
um will you train me and he's like will
you live in my house and train me uh for
like 30 days and then he did and then he
wrote a few years later he wrote a book
about that whole experience oh that's
cool this is before anyone who knew who
David Goggins was so the book came out
and he just calls it living with a
ceiling never mentions the guy's name
but he's like this character that's like
just like hard as [__] and just like you
know would wake him up like you know
three in the morning they just like they
would run like eight miles at night yeah
you'd wake up at three in the morning
and be like wake up [__] it's time you
know like he'd be like let's go we're
going running again again and again I
gotta read that it's a great book it's a
great read
it yeah living with a seal it's a good
uh a good one have you like for the
running thing is it like
why like I don't I'm like if you told me
to do an endurance thing I'd be like oh
you've suggested my least favorite
activity on Earth yeah yeah why do you
do it my parents did it growing up so it
it's kind of in my blood I saw them do
it
um
and I've always like they they raised us
like we would go on bike trips all the
time and so we were always doing it and
then we would see them do these
incredible Feats of fitness and it just
became something that I
that drove me and then I was like an
athlete in college and stuff so when I
graduated I was like I need something to
stay in shape so like running just
seemed like the most natural thing and
then
uh once you do you know five miles
you're like oh or once you do three
miles you're like I think I can do five
and then you're like ah I should I
should maybe go for a half marathon you
get kind of addicted to it right and
then
so I've done like marathons ever since
and then my sister signed up for an Iron
Man and she did it and she's my younger
sister so I was like damn it she did
that before me so then I signed up for
one and then I did one and now it just
kind of like through that I was going
through like a pretty dark period like
right after covid and uh
through training
for this for these I did an ultra
marathon first and then I did an Iron
Man and through training for those I
kind of like refound my confidence and
my happiness so now it's like something
I want to make part of my life so like I
started the training Channel
um and now I'm just planning more things
like I'm gonna do the New York Marathon
and then I'm planning 100 and something
mile altar that I'm trying to do what
about the music videos you guys do
because
um
they're amazing and uh
they're like almost like too amazing
it's like like where did this come from
why is this like why is this good are
you guys is this what you guys actually
do like I didn't really understand the
first time I saw one I was like this is
uh
I don't know I was just like very
jealous I was like holy [__] like you
can't have you can't be like Oh I'm
relatable and funny
but I'm also like Mega talented on the
other side it's like no no you get to
pick you know that's how life Works
um how did you guys start doing that and
why is it like why is it so
so [__] good and like why did you
lean it up more if it's so good
I do think that yeah like a lot of the
stuff I've done or been successful at
it's been like
like I'm the person to look at a pipe
dream and be like it would be really
cool to be that and then like actually
try and so that's kind of how that
started was like you don't count
yourself out you mean like yeah exactly
like I I
somewhere in me kind of believe that I'm
probably capable of that somewhere and I
think everyone is of everything
um but I'm pretty good at like not
you know turning myself down I guess at
the beginning and that's kind of what I
lost in that like dark period was I lost
that confidence and if I thought of
something I would revert back to like no
you couldn't accomplish that
um but when it came to music I was
always like it'd be cool to like do it
would be cool to like go online and say
I have a new song out you know what I
mean that would be a really cool
backwards from that yeah exactly and
like I never
I never played any instruments besides
drums growing up I was never really
musically inclined I had a good sense of
Rhythm and I really enjoyed music
and so I was kind of like now this is
something that's not really for you and
then I was like no why can't it be
and so I downloaded FL Studio I made a
beat and for one of our videos I invited
Noelle over because he used to actually
rap in high school
so I was like I made this beat can you
just wrap over it and we'll make a funny
song for the end of this video
and uh he you know took a little bit of
convincing because he was like I closed
this chapter of my life so finally got I
got him over to the place he you know
put a verse down
I recorded my verse I wrote and recorded
and then I was like tried to figure out
how to process a voice
which song about this horrible song
called keep your dick fat
and then which is a comedy song again
again the comedy is a nice crutch to
lean on where you're like we're bad but
it's funny yeah exactly so people don't
like put too much pressure on you or
make fun of you too much
and so we did that oh that's still up
wow okay
this is my first beat ever
it's horrible
yeah I like the beginning stuff I always
like the early stuff
foreign
how'd you decide on that as the concept
like what what didn't make it that this
one as the idea that's a great question
actually I totally forget how we even
came up with that I think he must have
said keep your dick fat or something and
then I was like oh that's funny let's
put that down well that's also how tiny
beat gang came out right like that
that's it was just yeah like just like
that was our whole thing it's just dick
jokes and being stupid and being five
years old
so and then so after we released this
uh we shot a music video for it and uh
where we like used a friend that was a
DP and we shot it all nice and then
we're like oh this is a fun thing like
doing something a little bit more high
production value this is like a really
fun path to go down and then shortly
after this I got a DM from a producer in
La his name's Diamond pistols now like a
fantastic friend and has produced a ton
of music for us
um he was like Hey I'm a producer let me
produce your next song this is really
funny and so we were like sure and we
showed up at his place
and we made a song called super Zan like
in a day or like we did we made that
song in a day and how do you make a song
so you get there I mean if you're
working with a good producer it's you
get there they're like what do you want
to make and you're like okay well I've
been listening usually the way a music
session starts is you'll just listen to
music together
and you'll be like I've really been into
this song recently you'll put it on try
to find some sort of inspiration
or if you come in with a concept then
you'll kind of work off that we didn't
really have anything and so he started
making a beat
we just like wrote some [__] lyrics
and then we came up with this concert
like at that time Xanax was like the big
thing like Lil pump and all these guys
were talking about doing Xanax all the
time so we were like let's make a song
called super Zan where it doesn't make
any sense because we don't actually know
what like mainstream rap lyrics mean
we're just kind of trying to you know
hang on to the trending references and
stuff like that
so then once we made that song we're
like it's the song is pretty damn good
let's shoot another video for it and
Noel called in a bunch of favors we
ended up getting a horse for the video
these look expensive too so you guys
like yeah this one was probably like you
made a bet you're like it's worth it yes
yeah I mean music videos are a money
pits at the time was that like kind of
like significant like is that like this
was like a lot of money oh yeah it was
we had nothing back then so it was huge
so like I said a lot of people did it
like on favors because they liked us and
that's Diamond Epistles you know a lot
of people that were in the video like
she was a paid actress but um are just
like friends and stuff and we knew
someone who had a horse and they brought
the horse and we paid them like 500
bucks or something wow uh so then we
released this on Spotify and it actually
got a lot of streams because people
watched the video because it was funny
so then we were like we should do an EP
Maybe
so then we started making more music and
then fast forward
two two EPs and albums later we signed a
music deal
with Arista
and we released two songs with them one
of them being broke [__] was now has
like over 50 million streams I think
Walkman has like 80 million or 90
million yeah I think I saw one was like
85 plus it's almost gold
was that is that 100 100 million gold uh
it's just like it's a hundred thousand
or it's 10 a million sales
it's a weird equation but I think it's
almost certified gold which is [__]
crazy that's a funny uh rap idea for you
like because everyone's always a
platinum yeah yeah it's like we went
gold yeah exactly so you
um that's good I like that yeah I might
steal that yeah I'm funny too okay one
of my questions on my list was like how
do I am I was am I funny and how do I
get funnier so I would say because you
listen to the Pod go ahead yeah I would
say you're definitely funny I chuckle I
think you guys
here I'll give you some constructive
criticism from a listener from a fan of
the show I think you need better cold
opens agreed a lot of times I feel like
you used the wrong moments well you
should use the funnier moments maybe
it's even dumber than that we come from
a different world so it's like uh
we're just dumb about like how you would
do a creative process it's like oh you
should care about this and like you
should run a process that like
like looks at the feedback or the data
and then like makes it better yeah or
like watch it together and be like what
could we do better yeah we've never done
that yeah but we should I mean I don't
know the show's good so that's like
that's my only little thing because it's
such a
it's such a great opportunity for a
laugh right before the smash cut to the
intro it's such a beautiful thing and so
we we tend to like take our cold opens
pretty seriously or like we need we need
a good laugh right at the beginning of
the show so when someone turns it on
they're like huh I knew I liked this
show another week you know
I'm sticking around one more weeks yeah
exactly I'll Stick Around for 10 minutes
exactly
section for you where I was going to
pitch you a slash oh yeah okay
we had one before you walked in it was
in s'mores yeah I was like why isn't
there something called Frozen s'mores
so why me though
well we have the idea of right before
you arrived and I was like I gotta ask
Cody about Frozen s'mores potential you
think there's potential there listen I
like so what we're gonna do here let me
tell you how this side how this came
about okay
I was like in the studio or whatever I
was like I want uh because this this
might look however it looks but like
we're in an office building and this is
like a small like
cubicle of office uh when we're here I
was like I want to buy an ice cream
truck and turn it into a podcast studio
and like roll it up to wherever we're
gonna whoever I wanna record with and
like yeah that's what Evo does he does
it in an ice cream truck it's not in an
ice cream truck but he has like a
sprinter van right that he's turned into
a little bit I was worried that much
people having a traveling set because he
pulled up right outside my house and I
literally like my commute was two
seconds so that's what I want to do yeah
it was pretty sick and uh so we're like
okay let's retrofit it and then Ben was
like you know well we gotta just create
an ice cream brand if we're gonna do
that and then yeah Frozen s'mores yeah
okay okay it's a s'more I see the cold
and the marshmallows vanilla ice cream
okay that's idea number one I have for
you that's good I like that yeah
marshmallows are my least favorite thing
about s'mores agreed agreed
um okay next one uh let's make a Netflix
show so I wanted to brainstorm with you
real quick okay a Netflix show
business related so business unscripted
that's the category okay so shark tank
is a great show yeah
we need more uh so like you know the way
like you know American Idol happened and
then the people were like oh [__] The
Voice X Factor America's Got Talent like
people just took that format and started
remixing masks singer like they they're
like people like this amateur singing
thing we're gonna do it yeah I think
people like the amateur business thing
yeah shark tank works yep there's not
really another shark tank uh there's not
like another remixed version of a cool
thing that you would want if you like
shark think you might like this so we
could do one for like creators so I
don't know just like what what would
work what do you think
I like the idea of doing it where people
like come in and Pitch their Channel or
they're like Tick Tock idea or whatever
this was uh Sully's idea last night he's
like yeah we need it for creators yeah
that's good I think I've heard
someone doing that I think because I've
that's not the first time I've heard
that idea right but I think it's an
awesome idea so like how would it work
so they come in you got you as a guest
as like a successful creators maybe are
the like judges or whatever what do they
get because like you know in a business
thing you're like I get
what does the contestant get like what
do they want
to create the to create their channel so
every Creator just needs money to fund
their idea I see
yeah and then you'd maybe like as a
judge you'd be like hey now I get like
10 of I'm your manager now I get 10 of
everything that you make right in the
future
yeah okay you're in I I was like it
sounds like you're in it's not I'm in on
both so far Okay cool so we're doing all
of these yeah we're Frozen s'mores first
clearly yeah second uh shark tank for
for creators yep
um another one uh app startup ideas okay
so cap that yep smash it yeah cap that
plus true smash I kept that too
I kept that two plus
was it two plus where it ended this
that's when traction started dying a
little bit have you had any and you were
almost
I say almost because I think your friend
best friend something like that started
Cameo so you were like very close also
to creating Cameo yeah or being a part
of Cameo oh yeah I could have been in at
the beginning
they were making that in my living room
and I was like this is you're like okay
guys cool yeah it looks cool what these
guys doing then I go record a YouTube
video like that's any cooler and uh and
then it blew the [__] up and then I
ended up investing in series a right and
I was like these guys were building this
beside me
well good for you because I anytime I
missed the first round it kills me to
come in later even though like you
should just come in it's like yeah and
I'm like so anchored yeah and you're
like the fact that they were in my
living it's out of the principle yeah
yeah I will lose more yeah exactly
so uh have you had any other like you
know viral app ideas that you haven't
pursued because you're busy being like I
had one famous one it was like it was
like um
it was like an app where you could
figure out where to buy Frozen s'mores
Frozen small locator yes exactly but
then I was like wait that doesn't exist
yet so someone has to invent that and
then I'm gonna make that app
yeah do you have any problems or pain
points or opportunities you've seen as
like you know your creator there's
tons of companies that Silicon Valley
like we serve the Creator economy yeah
but I don't think they really know or
understand really how creators lifestyle
is what they actually want have you seen
any
um like pain points or opportunities
that you think somebody who's
business-minded would go do I think AI
like has kind of revolutionized I mean
like it has everything but I think it's
there's a lot of potential there to help
creators whether it's with like
thumbnails something as simple as a
thumbnail or a title right like I've
noticed people using AI to make their
thumbnails stand out in crazy ass ways
what do they even use for that like what
are they I don't know but a lot of times
like they'll just make it look a little
bit cartoony but they'll they'll like
blend it with the original thumbnail so
that it's not gotcha obvious but it's
eye-catching you're like something's
weird about that thumbnail which is what
it takes
it doesn't it like you know people think
that a good thumbnail is like contrast
and colors and it's like a lot of times
that ends up blending in right you just
want to look different
so I think AI does that I remember in
history class at Duke actually I learned
uh that Hitler did that so back in the
day you and Hitler okay yeah wow like
mine's thinking like he all the posters
were colored like just like print there
everybody was and so he all of his
marketing was done in black and white
black and white Flyers posters whatever
yeah because it was just the contrast to
everything else and it was like yeah so
there you go take a page out of Hitler's
book what do you think about thumbnails
exactly
um but yeah I think there's other stuff
like for example both podcasting I know
there's so much with ads that you can do
the most obvious to me being like just
you know training some
you know AI on how we speak just feeding
at the transcript of our 500 episodes
right and then having it write the ads
for us in our own voice and then
actually synthesizing our voices and
reading the ads for us so we don't
actually have to record anything right
and then eventually just doing the whole
podcast
but like the ad thing I think is so
obvious it should happen right away and
if it's not already being worked on have
you uh had anybody like send you a link
to like here's you doing a podcast or is
he doing an ad yeah it's kind of I mean
we did it last time it was like uh I
forget the company's name but I think
they were looking for investment and
then I think I didn't reply to the first
email so the second one they're like
here here's you by the way here's your
voice and it was an app where you could
call you Elon for example and have a
conversation with Elon right on you know
your computer speaker basically and so
we called me on the podcast and both of
us just talked with me
and it was so [__] scary wow and
weird
you're like he's this guy's great yeah
yeah exactly that's funny I was like our
job is over right we're not gonna have
this job in a year you met Elon right
you yeah was it you went to uh you went
to his house I party with him one time
how was it tell me everything how does
that even happen we were uh this is the
first time I ever met post Malone
and we're like you know good friends now
I wouldn't I don't say that as a flex
I'm just like I [__] love the guy and
whenever he hits me up I'm down to hang
out uh but the first time he DMS me
which is often it's not often he's a
[__] rock star so it's like I don't
hear from him for eight months and then
all of a sudden he'll text me and he's
like I'm in town with them we're like
I'm like [__] yeah let's hang
um but he hit us up on or he hit me up
on Twitter and and all I think and was
like hey
dad or something like that like I love
your videos or something and I was like
oh my God I was a huge fan of his music
so I was like
it's like so thrilled and then he was
like I'm gonna I'm flying back from
Australia in three days or something
like that like let's get drinks and I
was like let's do it
and I think I was at I was with Kelsey's
family at the time my wife like at a
family dinner or something and he was
like I'm back in town let's meet at the
Rainbow Room in you know an hour and I
was like all right guys I gotta go sorry
Kelsey's family asked gotta dip out
um so we went met up with him at the
rainbow room and we got [__] up we
were drinking you know lemon drops and
and it was just like this surreal
experience where we're just like because
he's very simple he's the same sense of
humor so we're just like joking around
riffing having a great time and then he
looks at his phone he's like Elon elon's
been texting me and we're like uh yeah
sure yeah totally just thinking it was a
joke and then he showed us his phone it
was like Elon Musk it was like come over
and we were like
and he was like he was like should we go
over to his house and we were like uh
yeah I mean you can't really say no to
that yeah
and so
he got in cars and drove to his house
and uh we got to his house and him and
Grimes are like standing on the driveway
with lanterns
like welcome to what is that like I
don't know it was [__] it was so the
whole thing was from a dream I swear to
God it was the weirdest night of all
time was it like a thousand people there
or it's like just y'all no it was like
10 or not even it was like post crew
plus us these like you know Hangers On
they're just like I include me and [__]
and then it was Elon and Grimes and like
uh I forget who else was there a couple
like producers and like two other people
so we're all sitting around the fire
and it's like
two or three in the morning
and we're just sitting there talking and
posting Elon or talking and he's like
nursing a glass of whiskey or something
like that and I remember thinking like
this house doesn't have any furniture is
really weird
and someone was like well this is his
like Party House his like family houses
across the street or something
and I was like oh that makes sense he's
like a billionaired yes yeah exactly I
would have a party house if I could have
one
um with no furniture yeah and So
eventually and then and they're all
standing what so you're all standing no
no we're sitting outside of outside like
around a fire pit like on some ledge or
something like that I think there were
like a couple chairs they were very
sporadic
um and then I remember like we we
finally it was like 4 a.m I was like
okay I gotta go home Kelsey's asking
where I'm at and so we go downstairs
can't figure out which door leads out
and I was like I don't want to open a
random door and then there's like a
spaceship in there and they're like yeah
quick there's not enough time get on
so then I go back upstairs
and I like lean around the corner and
Elon and Grimes are making out and I was
like okay I'm not gonna interrupt that
so then we just went downstairs found
the door and then we're sitting both of
us you know all are sitting on the curb
afterwards looking up just like
what the [__] No One's Gonna believe
this like this is the wildest night
we've ever had
it was crazy that's insane what's he
like he was nice yeah he was nice I was
pretty drunk what is one talking my
memory is a little foggy but I remember
him saying some things that were like
okay he clearly like thinks a little bit
differently about things what did you uh
are you like like what's your in that
moment because whenever I meet
celebrities I make a complete ass out of
myself
um to the point where I'm like I don't
want to go and I don't want to meet him
I don't want to do it it's you know
I start thinking stupid things and I say
stupid things I think I like it was one
of those things where we were not
invited it was like posts that was
invited so he really wanted to get to
know post so they were talking and we
were sitting beside just kind of going
yeah
so yeah well I mean yeah totally I think
that's agree agreeing so we were trying
to like you know not be a nuisance right
that's a better mentality that's yeah
that's my new mentality with celebrities
just be there not be a nuisance and
don't yeah don't get people to wish you
weren't there
you know that's the new win yeah exactly
yeah because my win is like we're best
friends after this so what I need to do
is off this guy no yeah I was too scared
honestly that's hilarious dude this was
fun thanks for coming on yeah this was
great uh thanks for doing thanks for
having me appreciate it oh bye that's a
wraps
[Music]
foreign